g'day everyone welcome to some subs
channel
today we're going to talk about
reputation to be more precise we're
going to go over how reputation
doesn't actually exist and probably has
never existed a little bit philosophical
i know
but to explain what i mean by this
statement we need to first learn about
how reputation has changed throughout
time
some of the difficulties that come with
verifying reputation
and what the future holds for this topic
my name is lucas and it's time to
destroy the reputation of well
reputation
[Applause]
[Music]
in one of our previous videos we already
discussed identity and the issues around
this concept
one of the problems with identity was
the humongous amount of people who don't
have identification documents at all and
as a result have nowhere to prove who
they are
this situation is even worse when it
comes to reputation because nobody can
prove their reputation or dare i say it
their reputability when we verify one's
identity you can always learn that that
person is real but there's no
information beyond that if a person with
a valid identity fakes their reputation
you may risk being scammed at the same
time anyone can destroy your reputation
by accusing you or your business of
something like money laundering
obviously you can debate it in a court
of law but as we often see play out in
real life you'll have already acquired a
reputation as an untrustworthy person or
business character assassination
[Music]
so
your reputation can easily be damaged by
yourself or someone else
once your reputation is destroyed for
example with some old tweets dug up from
the past it'll be almost impossible to
recover it
so
reputation is both a fragile and
difficult thing to verify and this
combination creates a variety of
problems for you and an opportunity for
scammers
let's see if we can't find a solution to
this problem before explaining possible
solutions to make reputation provable
let's check again what methods people
already use today the most basic way to
support one's reputation is by providing
a recommendation letter from someone
whose reputation is more trustable this
method has been around for centuries
even in the famous book the three
musketeers by alexander dumas darthanyon
uses a letter of introduction written by
his father to excuse my french monsieur
treville
daratanyan needs this letter to prove
his worthiness and join the musketeers
in a similar way we now take
recommendation letters from our
employers or professionals essentially
people with an established reputation to
prove our own however this method is
highly unreliable for really several
reasons one of them is shown in a movie
by quentin tarantino called the hateful
eight
in the movie warren played by the lovely
samuel l jackson shows a personal letter
written to him by abraham lincoln
as warren explains this letter helps him
avoid fights with white people however
later on he confesses that the letter is
a fake and he simply used it as a
survival tool the fact that nobody
questioned the authenticity of the
letter is something that we often see
ourselves falling into when we accept
recommendation letters from other
people guys i've got some exciting news
for you tony our chief legal officer
here at some sub just released a new
interview with luke raven senior aml
compliance manager at capital a global
crypto investment platform
now in this video tony and our guest
will discuss risk matrix regulation and
technologies in crypto tips for mlros in
this industry and reasons why australia
is one of the enablers of ml we don't
have a
beneficial ownership registry
this is kind of like a quirk of
australia now i don't know about you
guys but i'll definitely be giving it a
watch
[Music]
let's talk about your cv
when hiring you hr specialists can try
to check the information you've provided
since now it's become much easier to do
so they can trace if you've received
certain certificates or organize certain
events they'll also look you up on the
internet of course
based on the response from over a
thousand hr professionals career
builders stated that 70 of them would
look you up on social media
in many cases a candidate's online
profile played a crucial role in their
chances to be hired
an example of this is sean breyer from
brea home buyers and he told a story of
how his company refused to hire a person
based on his social activity
brayer home buyers were convinced that
the candidate would fit the position but
they then found out that the person was
aggressively arguing political points
online
and this was enough to discourage them
from hiring them and the person didn't
get the job many job seekers understand
that employers may look them up
knowing this job seekers can delete
controversial information or change
their privacy settings
moreover they can intentionally create a
certain image of themselves online and
on top of that
anyone can make a linkedin profile and
write information about themselves it's
pretty simple it's much easier to get
someone to support your claims as well
for example you can fake that you've
studied at harvard add some harvard
alumni to your linkedin profile join
some university-related groups start
posting about the university and this
will probably be enough to fool
potential employers and make them
believe your reputation
sounds too good to be true well it's
time for me to introduce you to ali ayad
an influencer entrepreneur and former
designer at nike the ceo of mad bird and
a person who's never existed in 2020
when the job market was enduring the
repercussions of the pandemic a person
known as ali ayad created a fake company
to hire people and make them work for
free
ayad was abusing the fact that nobody
could verify him or his company's
reputation
mad bird the company had a website that
didn't look like a scam
all deceived employees were presented on
zoom meetings with 40 other people
most of whom turned out to be fake and
ali himself was praised on linkedin by
former colleagues and managers from nike
so any ordinary user who might have
decided to check ali ayad or his company
on the internet probably would have been
convinced that it was all real now even
if you aren't trying to fake a
university degree or places you've
worked you still probably want to
sprinkle a little bit of that extra
experience or just a dash of
qualifications that differ from the real
picture
once again with linkedin you can
convince your friends to support your
claims about your skills because
essentially nobody writes bad things
about you on linkedin it's one of the
perks
now what problems do we encounter from
this type of reputation building well
obviously fraudsters can abuse linkedin
in many ways
an example of this is fbi agents in san
francisco who investigated a series of
cases
where scammers were getting in touch
with people through linkedin
and then offering to make the money
through cryptocurrencies we know where
this is heading after looking at their
profiles victims were convinced of the
legitimacy of their reputation
and later the fraud says would send them
to fake websites and drain all their
money
mae mae so is one of the victims of such
a scamming scheme
a person who pretended to be a manager
at a fitness studio started texting
maymay in december 2021
after chatting for several months the
scammer shared how he could profit from
cryptocurrencies
by making transactions through a fake
crypto website
maymay lost over 228 thousand dollars
which was all of her life savings
companies can also become victims of
fraudsters faking their reputation a
common situation may be that you as an
employer hire somebody else your
employee who is under
or simply lying about their skills with
the ever-increasing amount of remote
positions you might never find out that
the person is lying since you never get
to meet them in real life
an example of this would be a person who
maybe worked in the u.s once in their
life at some point but isn't a us
resident they'll still have a social
security number with which they get
hired more damaging to your company may
be another situation where you hire a
person who is a counter agent from a
competing company
some corporate espionage and no matter
what your company does someone who may
be interested in stealing your product
could infiltrate your company with such
spice an example of this comes from 1997
gillette which is known for its razor
blades they won a lawsuit against a man
called stephen davis
stephen was working with the right
industries which was working with
gillette to design and fabricate
equipment for their new shaving system
as soon as he got the chance stephen
stole that information and shared it
with two other companies after being
caught stephen faced unfortunately 15
years of prison and hundreds of
thousands of dollars in fines so far
we've talked about reputation that you
or anyone else can create for yourselves
now let's go to a different point and
discuss the reputation that is based on
traces you leave about yourself
[Music]
let's talk about credit scores a credit
score is a number that represents a
person's trustworthiness their in a way
reputation
the us credit scoring system being one
of the most well-known ones
credit scoring is based on a credit
report which is usually written by one
of three companies experian transunion
or equifax
the report gets compiled from the
records of the banks and credit card
companies and other lenders sent to the
companies
each lender sends the information about
the client for free and then buys it
back in a compiled version from one of
those three companies
based on the credit report lenders can
then make a informative decision about
whether to give someone a loan or not if
they should hike up the interest rates
or not
to put it simply the better your score
is the better the conditions of your
credit will be
but we're not here to learn about how to
get a loan we're here to discuss
reputation essentially for lenders your
credit report is your reputation
the score that you get is a combination
of all the previous loans and debts
you've had
so if you don't pay your bills on time
your reputation will decrease at the
same time if you have had the same
credit card for many years successfully
banks will consider you a more
trustworthy client unlike with linkedin
or your cv this type of reputation does
get checked by a company and you can't
just write whatever information you want
yet
doesn't mean you can't trick the credit
card reports and gain a fake reputation
still
for example if you want to take out a
big loan and you don't have the credit
history you can take out a couple
smaller loans that you can easily afford
just to boost your credit score
we're not going to focus too much on how
to trick the us credit system if you
want to learn how to do that plenty has
already been said and a quick google
search will bring up plenty of
information
let's instead discuss the problems with
the system more generally
well first is that essentially three
companies control your reputation
obviously you can dispute the decision
of these reports if you have proof
but sometimes you might not even know
that something's wrong with their
evaluation
for example in 2017 the consumer
financial protection bureau reported the
credit report sent to american citizens
by equifax or transunion
differed from the ones that they sent to
the lenders as a result of this people
were deceived into thinking they had a
better credit score than they really did
this example supports the idea that
reports from only three companies with
their own interests probably isn't
enough to get a full or correct picture
of one's reputation
who would have imagined so
credit scores can say a lot about you
and your reputation
but there's still plenty of bias and
problems that lead to an incomplete
picture is there a way to create a full
portrait of someone's reputation well
there is something close to it and it's
called osins
[Music]
osint stands for open source
intelligence and refers to collecting
and analyzing information from open
sources
originally osint was used during the
cold war by the us to learn about life
behind the iron curtain without having
to send in real spice
at that time ocean specialists mostly
used radio broadcasts and newspapers as
their main source of information with
the development of the internet osint
has expanded to a variety of websites
scripts and procedures that allows
industry specialists to collect huge
amounts of data and separate them
today osint is still used by government
agencies as well as various businesses
certain companies such as bellingcat use
osin to track political events for
example and at the same time companies
can use osin to ensure that their
clients are trustworthy
how do the specialists do this well by
looking at the traces that you left on
the internet once you post something
online
it's there forever
and unlike a situation with your cvr
linkedin account you can't always
control which posts are up there because
it's just enough for you a friend or a
colleague or even a random person to
post a picture of you suddenly with the
development of ai recognition software
anyone can find all the photos of you
with your face on the internet
therefore if you want to fool an osint
specialist about your degree it will
take a much more concerted effort than
just claiming it on linkedin and adding
several people from a certain university
essentially all the actual information
about you can be found from open sources
and it's just a question of how deep the
specialist wants to dig
now
does it mean that ocean is a perfect way
to learn about someone's reputation
not exactly there are many downsides to
this approach first of all as i keep
mentioning your reputation can only be
traced by osin specialists all osen
tools are publicly available
for example you can go to ocean
framework and get acquainted with
various websites and these can maybe
help you find out someone's social
network
or you can get access to certain public
cameras but not everyone can learn how
to successfully use all these tools
correctly
the problem here is that barely anyone
can make conclusions about a person's
trustworthiness based on just the
information alone
in most cases you won't find an article
about a person saying this person is bad
then you should avoid working with them
mostly it'll just look like a bunch of
unrelated ordinary data and that's when
the specialist steps in and finds
patterns and relations between these
facts essentially an osint specialist
becomes a real life version of sherlock
holmes
so the first problem with osend is that
not everyone can use it the second
problem is that osen doesn't provide a
full portrait of a person
the specialists only work with the
tracks one leaves behind not with the
person themselves therefore if a person
for example has recently changed their
place of residence this information will
not be available to the osen specialists
until it reaches any of the open sources
and this fact can be used by people who
want to fool companies or in certain
cases the government about their place
of residency you could simply post
photos from your old house for many many
months while still living somewhere else
potentially someone smart enough could
find out about this deception by using
some sort of software noticing changes
in patterns but again it's going to
depend more on the specialist
professionalism rather than oceant as a
tool
[Music]
regardless of what type of reputation
we're talking about and how exactly this
reputation is being calculated we can
agree from all of these examples that
the importance of reputation is
increasing
reputation is an asset and unlike other
forms of assets you pay for this
reputation by your time and your actions
more importantly as warren buffett puts
it it takes 20 years to build a
reputation and five minutes to ruin it
if you think about that you'll do things
differently
we can see how this quote comes to life
with cases of celebrity such as kevin
spacey and his sexual harassment scandal
once you lose a good reputation or once
you require a bad image
people come to see you as toxic and
having any form of partnership with you
becomes toxic as well and while not all
of us are famous actors we can see how
with the increasing level of
globalization
any damage to your reputation becomes
easily googleable
now after looking at some forms of
reputation and exploring their
disadvantages in the way they are
assessed the question arises what's
going to happen to our reputation in the
future
will we keep relying on the qualities a
person claims to have in their cv or
will we keep paying to credit reports
from companies to learn about a person's
trustworthiness well vitalik butiran the
co-founder of ethereum is currently
working on a new form of reputation
building this year in may vitalik
announced that he wants to develop the
so-called soulbound tokens which are
essentially nfts that a person can earn
after achieving something
for example if you graduate from a
university you can get a sole bound
token proving that you went there
similarly principles will apply to
attending master classes or working at
certain companies
as butarian himself calls it soul bound
tokens are a form of an extended resume
however unlike the cv and linkedin
profiles we discussed before which you
can fake soulbound tokens need to be
verified by a person or organization
that provided it to you
all of these sold-out tokens and their
verifications will be transferred in a
sole wallet
importantly enough owners of these
wallets won't be able to sell their
tokens and this is probably the biggest
difference between this version and the
current version of nfts we know today
current nfts get sold and transferred
because of this feature nfts can often
get stolen by hackers sole bound tokens
however won't allow anyone to sell or
transfer these tokens minimizing the
risk of sbt thefts instead of selling
owners of sold wallets can only revoke
the tokens and in this way we can ensure
that a person actually holds a degree
and didn't just simply buy it from
someone else with such an approach
employers for example will be able to
verify your statements and get
confirmation from other owners of sole
wallets
with this approach we may shift from a
reputation with no proof
based on a company's opinion to a
reputation created by other people
now this may sound like an episode of
black mirror well as often is the case
here black mirror had a similar episode
where anyone could rate anyone for any
type of interaction
in this episode the constant fear of
losing your reputation
led to people being revoked from certain
services and created this weird society
of fear
luckily butarian's concept isn't as
dystopian as this one
it does raise many sobering questions
however
if we were to live in a world with soul
wallets would we all turn into people
who just try to please everyone around
us or will we just continue trends from
linkedin where everyone validates
everybody without ever giving a second
thought
or even would people just not care about
the system at all
let me know your opinions in the comment
section below i'd love to read about
your thoughts and ideas on this one how
can we improve reputation or even should
we
perhaps the safest way to size up a
person and know their character will
just be those real-life face-to-face
interactions
thanks for joining me again on this
reputable rant reasonably reviewing
reputation
don't forget to share and like this
video and subscribe to our channel we
want a good reputation after all my name
is lucas and i'll see you soon
[Music]
you